[Music]
April Fool's it's coming up and we bet
many of you are looking for new pranks
to pull on your family and friends need
inspiration don't worry we got your back
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up and subscribe to the things now let's
check out 10 hilarious kids who prank
their parents on April Fool's insect
slam okay
this one is actually really funny we can
imagine there are plenty of moms out
there that aren't really fans of bugs
come to think of it we don't know that
many people that really like bugs so
what is that our way to prank them then
to put a fake insect inside a lamp all
you'll need to make this trick work is
to buy a fake bug preferably a big one
but make it believable then tape it
inside the lamp that's frequently used
and make sure the tapes not seen an
awesome prank that clearly works
mysterious copies this one is just
hilarious and we salute the kid that
thought of it if your parent uses the
copy machine a lot you can sneakily
stick an image on top in this case this
prankster used Nicolas Cage since most
people don't open their copy machine
fully they'll probably wonder why it
keeps on printing the same Nic Cage face
on everything they copy you can go
really crazy with this one just make
sure you don't get in actual trouble
with your parents especially if you'll
end up wasting a lot of paper nail
polish so warning if you're planning on
doing this trick please make sure you
use soap that wasn't expensive get a
bottle of clear nail polish and the soap
your parents commonly used in the
bathroom then paint every part of the
soap and casually place it back because
we now polished makes the soap unravel
the soap will be useless but it will
take a while for people to actually
figure that out but seriously make sure
the soap isn't from some expensive and
fancy soap place cuz then you'll really
get in trouble airhorn Dora speaking of
trouble we have a feeling that's exactly
what happened to this kid airborne
pranks are fun because they're
incredibly loud but because of that they
can get you in a lot of trouble when you
use them on unexpected victims all you
need for this prank is of course an air
horn it works best on a door so just
tape it to a wall and make sure the
doorknob reaches the horn then just
your parents dope in the door and voila
this works perfectly on places like your
room because it definitely teaches a
lesson bug in slippers
here's another bug one since we know
most people really don't like anything
related to insects and bug prints are
always hilarious especially if they're
done correctly this one's pretty simple
but it all depends on how much is that
person afraid of bugs place a fake bug
in your dad's or your mom's the first
with this one you just need to hope that
they put them on barefoot and you can
bet they'll feel something weird inside
this reverb then just and watch the
freakout happen and celebrate a
successful prank that is unless you
hopefully don't get in trouble for this
fake audit letter okay this one is a bit
more complicated and you need to be
really careful when you do it but this
kid seriously nailed it being audited
means you receive a letter that tells
you you need to prove that you did your
taxes correctly a lot of people don't
which means they have to end up paying
more money but if you're up for scaring
your parents you can print a fake audit
letter this one works best if you change
small details into something funny just
so they know immediately it's just a
joke but their initial reaction would
mean you still succeeded in your praise
cups ah the classic cup Frank this one
seems to be a hit in schools but this
kid used it in their home and it seems
to have worked perfectly you need to
have a lot of patience for this and we
don't recommend doing
morning before your parents go to work
but if you were going to do it you need
about a hundred cups and fill them with
water place them carefully in the
hallway this might take some time since
you need to be precise but if you can
pull it off it can be one of the most
glorious pranks ever oreo toothpaste is
your bad luck Oreos this kid had the
right idea it might be a waste
especially since we all know the middle
part is the best part to pull off this
prank grab a bag of Oreos pull them
apart
remove the paste and replace it with
toothpaste this can easily be done with
a knife to make sure it's evenly spread
so it really resembles the Oreos you can
eat the middle part by yourself or share
it with your siblings as you laugh at
the thought of your parents eating an
Oreo with toothpaste in the middle trash
can scare you've probably seen the
hilarious clip of a kid trying to
unsuccessfully scare his dad in a trash
can his prank actually didn't work
because the dad ended up accidentally
throwing the trash on top of him but you
can definitely pull it off if you do it
correctly hiding the trash can until
your dad comes wait for just the right
moment and then jump out before he even
tries to throw in the bag it's a
guaranteed scare prank and a really good
one at that just be careful to make sure
you don't end up with trash all over
yourself shopping carts okay this one is
pretty funny imagine your parents go
grocery shopping on April Fool's and you
want to pull a prank on them but you
can't think of what if the store lets
you do this you can pull off one of the
most hilarious pranks ever by
surrounding your parents car with
shopping carts like this kid dead make
sure you do this during the time the
store isn't busy because we have a
feeling you can also easily print
thousands who want a shopping cart with
just one prank you can prank multiple
people in a totally unique and hilarious
way and that's all for our video don't
forget to subscribe to the things and
tell us how you felt about this video
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]